bienvenue dans le mât qui fait du bien
merci à tous ceux qui nous ont rejoints
et si notre ventre était notre premier
cerveau pour notre invité ce matin ce
n'est pas du bidon ce héros du quotidien
je l'assume pas celle-là
saillant armée d'un couteau Henri
n'avait lui qu'un sac à dos dans sa main
pourtant il lui a tenu tête quand j'ai
entendu les parents crier les enfants
crier et des parents sans faire avec
leurs enfants j'ai tout de suite compris
que c'était quelque chose de très grave
qui se passait et là sans réfléchir le
cerveau s'est débranché j'ai tout de
suite ta vie j'ai croisé la route de cet
homme et j'ai agi vraiment
instinctivement j'ai pas réfléchi j'ai
pour moi c'était impensable de rester à
rien faire et j'agis comme un français
devrait agir c'est-à-dire je suis mon
instinct et j'ai tout fait pour pour
protéger le plus faible bonjour Laurent
jacobelli bonjour vous êtes le roi de la
récup comme d'autres comme ericsiotti
comme Eric Zemmour c'est-à-dire vous
avez tout de suite voulu réagir et faire
le procès de l'immigration en Europe
alors que le drame de se produire alors
juste un mot avant de répondre à votre
question je vais pas me défiler
rassurez-vous mais un mot pour les
familles qui en ce moment attendent de
savoir sur leur bébé si leur gamin vont
vivre survivre en urgence pour mourir
parce qu'il y a deux enfants en urgence
et je pense qu'on doit tous penser à eux
et je pense qu'on le fait tout ce très
sincèrement je réponds à votre question
et vous vous faites de la récup après
cette intervention Henri 24 ans pour
chasse dans le parc la saillant qui sera
maîtrisé quelques instants plus tard il
y avait d'autres personnes qui ont couru
avec moi aussi à ce moment-là notamment
aussi des des jeunes personnes et
d'autres un peu plus vieilles j'ai eu
peur pour ma vie oui c'est normal j'ai
vraiment eu l'impression d'un homme
complètement fou vraiment plus du tout
en possession de ses moyens habité par
quelque chose de très mauvais entre vous
qui êtes dans les excès et entre
l'extrême gauche qui est dans le déni
aujourd'hui nous qui voulons être modéré
qui voulons aborder la question de
l'immigration aborder la question de
l'extrémisme de tout bord aborder la
question du logement aborder les
questions de la pauvreté et ben c'est
simple on trouve plus elle est où la
Légion d'Honneur bah c'est j'étais en
costume craque je me suis changé
hier cet après-midi depuis Annecy Henri
a rencontré Emmanuel Macron
petite demande
j'étais honoré
merci beaucoup
parce que depuis hier vous avez prié
Henri
j'ai envie de dire j'arrête pas la
médaille a été remise par Nicolas
Sarkozy et donc c'est comment il vous
dit quoi il fait un discours
très sympa vous prenez tous les
compliments ça fait plaisir en fait
notre cerveau il adore quand on est
reconnu par les autres c'est une
fonction sociale qui vient de l'aube de
l'humanité on est des êtres sociaux on a
besoin d'être admis par le clan par la
société et donc en quelqu'un nous donne
exactement c'est ça et du coup à chaque
fois à chaque fois qu'on reçoit un
encouragement qu'on reçoit une marque
d'attention et bien notre cerveau il
nous donne il nous fait une sorte de
cocktail hormonal en fait il nous donne
une récompense en fait notre cerveau est
un dealer si sur le voie comme ça
c'est très émouvant et quel type
d'émotion bah une émotion de d'un gars
qui est arrivé en France sans rien qui a
grandi dans une famille modeste qui
avait ni argent ni pistons ni copains
que c'est démerdé tout seul et qui a
réalisé le rêve français n'ont pas le
rêve américain moi je suis pour qui est
une immigration dans ce pays je suis
pour qu'elle soit organisée je suis pour
que on soit bienveillant avec eux j'en
fais partie mes parents en été les
bordel il y en a marre il y en a marre
parce que je vais vous dire alors je
vais vous dire quand je voyais hier
comment les gens ont traité la question
d'Annecy mais c'est effarant ce que j'ai
fait tout le monde l'aurait pu faire
tout le monde aurait pu le faire pardon
et tout Français devrait le faire et
peut-être aussi
j'inviterais ceux qui nous écoutent à se
recentrer vraiment sur l'essentiel pour
garder justement à l'esprit ce qu'il y a
de plus beau et et de plus grand
acle les quatre enfants âgés de
1 mois après leur disparition dans la
jungle sur ces photos diffusées par
l'armée les enfants le visage émacié et
les raffaiblis sont pris en charge par
les secouristes
ils étaient seuls ils ont réussi par
eux-mêmes
c'est un exemple de survie totale qui
restera dans l'histoire
un sauvetage historique car les enfants
hérissent dans l'immensité amazonienne
depuis le crash de leur avion c'était le
premier mai dernier trois adultes dont
leur maman avait été retrouvés morts à
côté de l'épave depuis d'importants
moyens de rechercher des mobilisés pour
seul preuve de vie les enfants ne
laissaient derrière eux que quelques
fruits mordus des baskets ou bien encore
un biberon aux États-Unis ce sont 37
chefs d'incubation qui ont été retenus
contre Donald Trump les perquisitions
menées il y a quelques semaines à son
domicile de Floride ont permis de
retrouver regarder ses photos des
centaines de cartons qu'il avait
récupéré après son départ de la Maison
Blanche certains étaient stockés dans
une salle de bain à l'intérieur des
documents classés secrets défense c'est
qu'il lui vaut d’être notamment
poursuivi aujourd'hui pour rétention
d'information portant sur la sécurité
nationale et puis Donald Trump n'a pas
fait que
conserve qui aurait concerné normalement
l'Iran et bien il l'a montré à un de ses
proches et tous les enregistrements
montrent que Donald Trump savait très
bien que ces documents n'étaient pas
déclassifiés lui aujourd'hui Clem son
innocence et explique que c'est une
machine à Sion politique pour l'empêcher
de gagner la présidentielle de 2024 il
l'avait dit Vladimir Poutine en 2017
celui qui détiendra et dominera le monde
aura l'intelligence artificielle avec
lui
absolument c'est un outil de puissance
la technologie l'a toujours été en
réalité et si on remonte vraiment dans
l'histoire de l'humanité le papyrus
était une première révolution en tant
que telle ce que tu peux me dire ce que
raconte cette épicerie c'est la
tapisserie de l'apocalypse de gens
tisser au 14e siècle pour évoquer tous
les fléaux du 14e siècle donc la guerre
de Cent Ans oui la peste
140 mètres de long sur 6 mètres de haut
c'est une bande dessinée XXL
avant de se quitter je voulais vous
montrer à tous ces images d'intelligence
artificielle avec des visages que vous
allez peut-être reconnaître regarder des
visages de leaders politiques
devenu enfant Joe Biden que l'on que
l'on découvre c'est assez surprenant une
nouvelle fois c'est aussi ça ce pouvoir
de l'intelligence artificielle ils n'ont
en tout cas là qu'un regard et un visage
d'enfant